- [Voiceover] Adjust
the leading coefficient
and vertex coordinates to make
the blue parabola match
the orange parabola.
Now we've already seen how we can go
about shifting these parabolas.
If we subtract something from y,
it actually shifts the
parabola up by that amount
and we've already talked about that
in the video on shifting
and scaling parabolas.
But let's actually see it in practice
cause this is actually going
to allow us to experiment.
We'll see if we increase this,
that's actually shifting it down.
While if we decrease it, it shifts it up.
But we actually do have to shift it down
for this example.
Now at least the y-value of our vertexes,
vertices look the same.
Similarly, when we shift the,
whatever we are squaring,
whenever we, if we shift,
if we subtract a value here,
it shifts it to the right,
while if we add a value here
it shifts it to the left.
Let's verify that.
If we subtract a value here,
it shifts it to the right
and if we add values here
it shifts it to the left.
Just like that,
it looks like I've been able
get our vertices to coincide.
This vertex right over here is
at the point x=-4, y=-3.
It's no coincidence.
x=-4 makes this zero
and y=-3 makes this zero.
But these parabolas still don't match up.
This yellow parabola
seems to increase faster.
The scaling factor right over here seems
too low for our blue one.
Let's increase it.
There we go.
If we put a two there,
it's growing fast enough.
If we put three there
it's growing too fast.
If we put a zero there,
it's a flat line and
then it becomes negative.
Let's bring that back
to just +2.
And we are done.